hi
my name is bob sutton i'd like to
welcome all of you to our webinar
and and what i'm going to do today
is for the next 40 minutes or so talk
about some ideas that my colleague huggy
rao and i spent
about seven years developing and and to
sort of give you a bit of context huggie
and i are both essentially management
or professors i study more the
psychology of work he studies more the
sociology of work
and we do a lot of different programs
together including we lead
one executive program called customer
focus innovation
um which um which in which we try to get
participants to
think about how they can develop and
spread um innovations and ideas to
essentially please customers and have
more empathy for them and in the process
of
doing this program in about 2006
we noticed that people kept asking the
same question which was
there's a little pocket of my
organization a little place
maybe an office maybe a little group
where people are really great at
pleasing and anticipating the needs of
customers
the challenge is how do we spread it
more why more widely throughout the
organization
and so we didn't have very good answers
so we started thinking about that
and we started doing case studies we
started scouring the academic literature
and along the way over the last six or
seven years we built sort of
i would describe it as a cadre of 40 or
50 folks who in various ways had faced
similar problems
so so essentially that's what the book
oops that's what the book is about and
here's here's the book which just came
out a couple months ago
and and to give you a sense of the
challenge that we
tried to wrestle with um in this book
scaling up excellence is
essentially you've got an organization
maybe a network of organizations
and there's a little pocket of goodness
something that's really
um quite excellent how do you spread it
from the few that have it to the many
who need it
and how do you do it in such a way and
you know we're jokingly calling this
webinar scaling up without screwing up
but i would say how do you do it without
messing up less because it's impossible
to do it without making a lot of
mistakes frankly
and let me give you some examples
uh one of the examples we talk about a
lot in the book is a little startup that
came out of stanford called
pulse they were recently acquired by
linkedin for 90 million dollars uh
started by two guys
and actually two students and we we
kind of tracked them as they went from
four to twenty employees it was really
quite interesting the growing pains they
have is they
just added a few people so that would be
one example sort of a crazy example
got something like mcdonald's which uh
is in the process of opening some 1500
stores in china
another example for those of you
interested in spreading innovation a big
interest of ours
there's one of the heroes in the book is
a woman named claudia kochka
she started out with just a little group
in procter and gamble that was trying to
be more customer focused
and in fact their first client was mr
clean which in those days was just
liquid cleaners
and she helped that by by being more
customer focused about
all these products and now there's
actually some 300 people
throughout procter gamble who do
essentially innovation or customer focus
design a group that she helped
create and lead and and then finally one
of our favorite
and most important examples which is in
the us as much as we hear about
how bad our health care system is there
is some good news
one of the case studies that we did and
we've had extensive conversations with
is something called the hundred thousand
lives campaign and what happened was a
small non-profit out of boston
called the institute for health
improvement led an effort
to spread actually very simple measures
that reduce the number of deaths in u.s
hospitals
things like getting doctors and nurses
to wash their hands things that simple
and it looks like and my colleague huggy
rao is a great quantitative researcher
has some evidence that that it looks
like these changes
did probably save about a hundred
thousand lives but in all these cases
although they vary the challenge is
how do you spread something good from
the few
to the many um so the book has lots of
ideas but if we were going to pick our
core message
is is that um one of the the things
about scaling people tend to
view or think of scaling as just doing
more and more and more and more of
something
and that's part of it we describe that
as sort of creating a footprint
but the other part of it is also
this notion that when you're spreading
something good
what really propels and sustains it is
the mindset the set of behaviors and
beliefs
that people live and accept and in
particular
the question we tend to ask when we go
into organizations
to get a sense of them is what is sacred
here
and what is taboo so this isn't in the
slide deck but just to throw in a quick
example it's pardon me um about um six
weeks ago i was giving a talk at amazon
this
diverse group it was it's called their
fishbowl for authors
about 160 170 folks and people are
everything from the grocery business to
the book business
they have a new grocery business to uh
to people in the server
business they kind of do a lot of stuff
like that and um and i asked them what's
sacred here and what's taboo
and even though they're from many
different businesses they said what's
sacred
at amazon is the customer and they
really do mean that if you've ever dealt
with
amazon and what's taboo is wasting money
they're one of the cheapest
organizations i've ever dealt with in my
life
but one thing that helped is everybody
understood what where they were supposed
to
devote their attention another example
and this one's important um not just
because facebook's sort of on one of the
modern darlings
but it's also important because one of
the things that we always found
was that especially when organizations
scaled
very quickly grew very quickly that
having a focus
on um on getting every keeping everybody
on the same page in terms of this notion
of what's sacred and what's taboo
and instilling the same mindset in them
was really important to propel growth
especially as you're adding people
quickly so
you can see the numbers how quickly they
grew and one thing they do it
on facebook and i just checked a couple
weeks ago they're still doing it
is when you are brought in as a new
engineer
what they do is they have an idea sort
of what your job is going to be but
they're not completely sure
and what they'll do is they'll give you
12 or 13 little assignments
to actually code make changes
in the website and and so what you're
doing is you're living the move
fast and break things mindset and and
it's
so they talk about a little bit but
what's happening is they're really sort
of instilling it in people
and when we ask chris cox who's quoted
here on the slide who's
who's now he keeps getting different
jobs but now he's had a product
um and essentially he's been sitting
next to mark zuckerberg for 10 years i
think that's the most important fact
about him he's been called
various things but he usually sits next
to mark all day
and um and so his definition of a
successful first week at facebook is
you've made a change that you can
in the website that you can show your
parents i thought that was sort of cute
now one thing that um i hasten to add is
that successful mindsets will vary
depending on the nature of the business
so when i was talking to a vmware
executive about the move fast and break
things mindset
his perspective was that that might be
great for facebook but we can't use it
in our business for example they make
software
for nuclear submarines and it move fast
and break things does not seem like a
good idea
in that situation um the one constant
though we do tend to see
to quote brad bird the famous director
um
from pixar he's done ratatouille the
incredibles
is there's this kind of relentless
restlessness this feeling that things
are never quite good enough and we've
always got to keep improving
but again the key idea here is that in
order to scale excellence one of the
things that propels it
is is this really clear notion of
of what's sacred and what's taboo in an
organization
okay so here's essentially the little
agenda we're going to go through let me
start out with our big lessons
two we've got two of them that are
important our first big lesson
is that when we look to see
what kind of propels the spread of
excellence in organizations
we see organizations where people have
what we would call
felt accountability another way to put
it is
something happens in the organization so
people have the feeling that i own the
place and therefore i have to do my job
really well and also that the place owns
you
and so there's a sense of mutual
obligation where everybody feels not
only obligated to do their job well
but to teach and to even criticize
co-workers who are not
um performing up to stuff or need to
learn something to do their job better
and in the just one quick example we've
got this uh
this little study done by a consortium
of hospitals to try to figure out well
what is it about
the 15 of us hospitals where when uh
when a patient is
you know unfortunately has is dying
or has in some cases just already died
and the
organs need the organs can be harvested
to help save other people's lives
in most hospitals in that situation is
about 50 of the time they're successful
getting permission
and harvesting the organs but there's a
few hospitals that have
over a 75 percent rate and what's
special about them
and in those hospitals this study
indicated they had kind of an all
teach all learn kind of mindset
and everybody in the hospital who could
possibly have an impact was involved
not just the doctors and the nurses the
receptionist the clergy
and they would have sort of frequent
huddle meetings to figure out how we can
all work together
to make sure that this happens and that
feeling of sort of
mutual responsibility all teach all
learn is the hallmark
for us of organizations that spread
excellence one of the hallmarks
um and and the other thing of course you
see here is that scaling starts and ends
with those individuals it's not just
something that comes down from on high
the second big lesson is that as we put
it is that scaling is a problem of both
more and less
so we think of scaling we think of
adding more and more and more and more
but along the way things build up or you
do stuff that you probably should get
rid of
and so the the best leaders and teams
are constantly thinking about what they
can subtract what they can remove
from uh from the system to give you and
and
of course all sorts of things build up
that we forget about here's this little
cartoon which i got
i bought it from the new yorker
permission years ago so i love using it
they're wearing the stupid hats and it
says i don't know how it started either
all i know is it's part of our corporate
culture and there are many things that
become
part of a corporate culture that sort of
become like these this baggage that we
all drag with us and in good
organizations they're constant people
are constantly mindful about what to get
rid of
um sometimes of course this reaches
extreme levels there was this of course
incredible incident
in the u.s about um eight years ago uh
when um essentially the president united
states fired the ceo of general motors
and brought in the guy
ed whitaker who had been ceo of at t and
ed did a pretty good job of kind of
running around gm which is a
at least was a very ossified
organization and getting rid of things
and you can see the example
in the r d organization they cut the
number of reports from 94 to 4.
the other thing that happens is that as
organizations grow
things that really were useful at one
stage start becoming a hindrance at
another stage so
the the sort of famous saying you
sometimes see in the management
literature
what got you here won't get you there um
one organization that
i've been involved in since the 90s ideo
it's led by david kelly david's the
founder of ideo also
uh the primary founder of the stanford
d-school or hassel plattner institute of
design
that was mentioned in the introduction
and in the mid-90s
i used to go to all hands meetings in in
palo alto on mondays
and and they looked you can see the
pictures that's pretty much how they
look usually we'd be lying around some
cold
ugly warehouse and you can see the guy
lying in the middle who looks like
groucho
marks that's david kelly and david would
just do this masterful job of leading a
meeting with 150
or with 60 people and everybody would
feel included and he'd mention most
people's names and
he'd kind of leave being charged up but
then when ideo hit 150 that didn't work
at all and they had to divide it up
and this happens classically in
organizations
and finally and this is the really tough
stuff to get rid of
is in many organizations things are done
that well just because everybody else
doesn't supposedly you have to have them
and my favorite example is performance
evaluations
if you looked at research on performance
evaluation if you sort of think of it as
a drug
it would not get government approval fda
approval to be
spread on the market as sort of a cure
for anything because about forty percent
of the time it makes things better
forty percent of time it makes things
worse and twenty percent of the time it
has little
effect at all so there are some
organizations that are starting to have
the courage
to get rid of performance evaluations
and replace them with something else
a good example is this is one of the
heroes of our book donna morris who's
head of hr of adobe
donald looked at the numbers and every
year around performance evaluation time
uh they discovered that their best
people would leave uh
at an increased rate that employee
satisfaction would go down
go throughout the firm and that it took
80 000 person hours
so they got rid of them and switched to
a system of sort of
constant check-ins and they essentially
is the way she put it
we took the forms away from the managers
and we required them
to talk to employees about how they were
doing it it's more complicated than that
they did a bunch of changes but right
now we're actually in the middle of
doing a more in-depth case study and
it's described in the book there's a
couple pages in the book
but essentially all the evidence is is
that
there's all sorts of positive
consequences people like the new system
better
and in particular if you will the right
people are
are leaving and the right people are
staying and so this is one of those
cases where they kind of had the courage
to get rid of
something that was causing friction and
to spread excellence
okay let me talk a little bit before we
get to the principles about the key
choice point
in the process of doing this book
there's lots of little
different decisions that we look at that
are important for spreading excellence
but there was one that just came up over
and over and over again it never goes
away
and we're we're not i'm trying to like
be overly serious about this but the
analogy we use is catholicism versus
buddhism
so as you scale there's just about
always this decision which is how much
standardization
would you call catholicism would you
have um
in in an organization as you spread
different ways of doing stuff
or would you have a general sort of
approach or set of beliefs
and and sort of allow local variations
is our friend
michael dearing a venture capitalist who
came up with this distinction
former altar boy of the month he always
likes to point out um
michael dearing says in some
organizations you have a
few general beliefs and people can do
what they want in other organizations
you have a very refined
playbook if you want an example of
organization out here in the west that
has a very
very standardized approach every store
is pretty much exactly the same
you can uh see in and out burger that's
their entire menu right there
uh very few ingredients they're they're
owned by the all stores are owned by the
corporation
and if any of you have ever been to an
in-n-out burger the employees
seem to look the same and act the same
in the sort of a universe so we sort of
perky sort of upbeat helpful way
they are very clear about who they are
and it's very consistent across
across locations there does sometimes
turn into a problem though when you try
to replicate things exactly
every place you go sometimes something
that works great in one place will not
work in other places
a great example is what happened when
home depot went into
china the chinese market home depot in
the united states is a do-it-yourself
sort of store you go there you buy the
stuff you assemble it or do whatever at
home
do your home maintenance project well in
china which is
rather than a do-it-yourself culture
it's mostly do it for me culture
they open 12 stores in china and they
all
ended up closing them in the last few
years they're all gone because it did
not work in that culture and
one of my chinese students is he put it
if in china
in addition to having a do it for me
culture in general if you have enough
money to shop at home depot
you have enough money to pay somebody to
do the work so it
so culturally it just didn't work in
contrast ikea which has been
fantastically successful in china
they kind of sell the same stuff they do
everywhere else in the world there's a
few custom products for the market but
not many
but the main difference in terms of what
happens in china is
that they put in better delivery and
assembly services than anywhere else in
the world so they customize it to the
culture
and just as a kind of cute example that
we talk about in the book
there's a hotel chain out here in the
western united states
called joadave hotel started by a guy
named
chip conley he actually recently sold it
to hyatt and is now
senior executive at airbnb but he spent
some 25 years
at least 25 years building the chain of
hotels
and the method that he would use is what
he called the magazine method
which is whenever he opened a boutique
hotel he and his team would figure out
the magazine that would sort of
symbolize and guide their approach to
running the hotel and
the way they designed things and
each hotel had a different magazine so
to give you an example there's one in
san francisco called the renaissance
which was their first hotel
and the magazine they chose was the
rolling stone kind of like rocker type
folks
and there's actually a new one in palo
alto um one of the last ones chip did
before
he went off to airbnb and the magazine
they used was wired magazine
so so this idea of sort of local
customization
is important just one quick um
sort of caveat and uh and maybe in the
questions we can talk about this some
but um there's there's lots of
elements of this decision but one of the
key elements that i always kind of worry
about
is that this notion of all of us being
able to do whatever we want sounds just
great
but um there's there's quite a few
situations where people feel so
snowflake special
that they're not going to do stuff even
if it's in the best interest of the
clients in the organizations and
possibly themselves because they don't
like being told what to do
and a great example is in medicine and
in particular you can see on the slide
there was this great story that atul
gawande tells in the new yorker
a guy named dr john wright spent um
years
essentially babbling his colleagues and
convincing them
that when it came to replacing uh knees
so doing knee replacement surgery
that they should standardize the
hardware they put in and
surgical techniques and anesthesia
techniques and recovery techniques
and and eventually he kind of won the
battle and you can see the statistics
cut costs by 50
whole bunch of other positive outcomes
uh
but um you know many of his colleagues
still sort of despise him for making
him conform so that's always an issue
with catholicism and
buddhism one of the advantages of
buddhism is that people have feel like
they have more ownership for it
but this sort of unwanted variation can
sometimes undermine
performance okay in our final 20 minutes
what i'm going to do
is kind of zoom through some of our key
principles and we'll have a couple of
takeaways at the end
there's our principles the first one is
one of those things that you know and i
know many of you
are i i guess like me kind of like
rational types
that if you just make a rational
argument you think people should
adopt and spread the mindset that you
want them to do you know spread the
excellence
lots of evidence that that if you just
make a rational argument human beings
tend not to be actually moved
particularly to action
and lots of research shows as huggy raw
would put it
that what happens is if you want to
actually bring about change spread a
mindset spread new ways of doing things
you combine sort of two things one if
you get the emotions cranked up you get
a hot cause going
and then you link that to specific
tangible actions
so to give you one example we already
mentioned the hundred thousand lives
campaign
there were two key speakers at their
kickoff event so what they did was they
invited about four thousand
key folks in the um in the hospital and
medical care industry so
executives from large hospitals folks in
the american nursing
and american medical association
so doctors and nurses folks from key
insurance companies
and they said please sign up for our
campaign we believe it will save many
lives
and they had two speakers one soro king
described how her daughter josie
died at johns hopkins hospital and said
to the folks out in the audience
if this hospital had been in the hundred
thousand lives campaign my daughter
would not have died
so that sort of like hot cause cool
solution and then
um another one of the speakers sister
mary jean ryan
who at that time ran a large catholic
hospital chain essentially said speaking
of catholicism that there's a moral
imperative for this so
you know sort of like maybe you're
risking eternal damnation was sort of my
interpretation so you should join the
campaign so hot cause cool solution
and just as a quick aside this idea of
high cause cool solution
it can also be in the name of something
not just saving lives
if you look at the battle of the beers
this was one of the key kinds of
rhetoric that they used in the early
days the people in the industry
to get the emotions cranked up they if
you read the quote
they talk about um coors and corona as
if it was sort of like this immoral
thing
um and even that's sort of silly it did
get the emotion sort of cranked up and
now we have the craft beer movement in
the united states
the key thing when you're doing this is
you want to arouse collective pride or
aggression
it not just one person when you get sort
of that collective emotions important
all right the second one is
although it's great to make an argument
and get the emotions cranked up and
everything
there's lots and lots of evidence that
if you really want to cement a mindset
that you're spreading
the most important thing is to get
people to live it lots of great social
psychology studies show
that no matter what people are saying to
start with as long as they're kind of
marching in the direction you want to go
their minds will change because you get
this inconsistency between their
behaviors and their beliefs and they
want to close that cognitive dissonance
and to go back to facebook when we
interviewed chris cox
his perspective was well we give him a
little welcome talk and
in fact chris himself usually does the
welcome talk at facebook
still and then what we do is we send
them off to make some changes in the
site because
the way they learn it is by living it
and and
there's a footnote here which is really
important for those of you who are
trying to if you will convince other
people to change
which is even if they're complaining and
don't really want to do it and don't
seem to believe in it
that if you can get them marching in the
right direction
there's a lot of evidence that they will
eventually change as long as they are
doing of their own volition
and one of my favorite examples that we
go through in some detail in the book
is one of our our heroes and friends
bonnie simmi
you can see her there at the controls of
a plane well bonnie's a senior executive
at
jet blue airlines also a three-time
olympian and
she's also still an active pilot so sort
of a superwoman type
and she's amazing and some of us may
know that jetblue had all sorts of
problems especially
in 2007 where when storms hit airports
they
they actually at one point had a couple
thousand people sitting on planes at
kennedy
for as long as eight or ten hours
terrible sort of pr fiasco and also
their system wasn't working that well
when a when a storm hit for example
so bonnie led what after some failed
attempts to fix it by senior executives
who brought in consultants or
tried to do top-down changes she led an
effort where
the way it started was she brought
essentially 40 people in a room
from all different parts of the company
pilots
people who did operations flight
attendants reservations agents all sorts
of people
and had them map the process of closing
and then reopening kennedy airport new
york when a storm hit
and every place where there was a
problem that needed to be fixed they put
a pink post-it note and
the process was we'll get rid of the
pink post-it notes and then the system
will work
so she has the first group spend the day
doing this and then she asks them
so how many of you think this will work
not one of them raised their hands
but she had them kind of marching the
right direction she said can i get you
to come back for just one more time
and then can i get you to nominate a
friend and by and after a few months
they kept marching in that direction two
things happened was they started
believing it
and the second thing that happened is
all signs are that they fix the system
as a result of this this sort of
bottom-up sort of system that
bonnie led okay
the next one is cut cognitive load but
deal with necessary complexity
lots of evidence that when you weight
down people with
excessive load put weight on our brains
that we lose our will
and also we tend to do everything um
badly and some of us uh as somebody
who's
who has like kids who claim to be
digital natives and therefore they can
multitask
there's all sorts of evidence especially
from our dear friend the
the late cliff nasa at stanford that
that nobody can multitask and even
multitasking makes everybody stupid no
matter how smart they might be in other
ways
and even it turns out that heavy
multitaskers are worse at multitasking
than light multitasking
multitaskers because we have cognitive
limits
and one little experiment i love that
shows that
especially when you give people
cognitive load they sort of lose the
will to do the right thing
baba shiv our colleague from the
stanford business school did a famous
study where
he had people memorize either two digit
numbers or seven digit numbers
and walk down a hallway to report it to
an experiment at the other end
they were offered cake and fruit those
who were
offered those who had the seven digit
number to remember
fifty percent of eight fifty percent
more take and presuming that you know
fruit is better for you than cake what
happened was the load love that
led them to sort of lose the will to do
the right thing
now organizations do this to us all the
time just to give you a quick example
and know you're not supposed to be able
to read and interpret this quickly i
don't think anybody could
um some years back five or six years
back into it
tried to have a design for delight or
design movement
and this picture this messy picture with
this very long title
this was what they sort of rolled out to
employees and
and they had scott cook who is the
co-founder of the company and
some other senior executives presented
to hundreds of employees
and they had two reactions one was they
couldn't understand it
and the other was this too shall pass so
this
they were presented this way but they
figured out pretty quickly since these
are smart people
that may be going to something more
simple that um if you will put less
cognitive load on people and was more
discernible was
possible now one thing i like to really
emphasize
at this point is that i'm not
making a simple argument that you need
as much simplicity as possible
because there are all sorts of evidence
that as organizations grow
and this is a big challenge in scaling
they do need more
hierarchy they do need more structure
and they do need more process
you just want to make it as light as
possible and the reason i have to ask
larry page there
there's a great point in google history
early on in about 2002
where larry decided that he was missing
the good old days when it was just
him and sergey and a few folks in a room
they'd grown into 400 and they had all
these managers he wanted to get rid of
the managers so he did
and for a very short period of time
there was one executive who had a couple
hundred engineers reporting to him
didn't work at all and google went back
to managers and if you
look at the modern google great company
that it is the first line manager is
viewed as one of the most important
people at google so
they tried the experiment of if you will
subtracting too much
and again maybe we can talk about the
sum in the q
a the some of the basic guidelines
instructing the ballot
the balance i think comes especially
from chris frye one of the scaling
heroes in the book he's now head of
engineering at twitter
did some great scaling at salesforce.com
and
his perspective is that what's your job
is as
as a leader or a manager of either a
group or a large organization
is to use the hierarchy to destroy bad
bureaucracy
because it's not that organizations
don't need things that are
really trappings of bureaucracy
structure process titles managers
they just need as few as possible and
chris has a great test which is that
if it feels like the people are walking
in muck that's a sign that i've got too
much structure
one other quick thing which is that
there's
a lot of evidence that as your
organization grows
one of the most important things for you
to do is especially to keep
the team small and essentially you've
got the examples there that navy seals
fire teams have four members soda
mckinsey engagement teams and
essentially what the evidence shows
especially if you think if you go from a
team of four or five to ten or eleven
that the amount of time that people
spend on coordination tasks
goes up exponentially and also the
amount that
they have dysfunctional in sort of
relationship problems
in in the organization or in the team
also goes up
an example i like to give is think of
the difference between going to dinner
with three or four people
you can keep a conversation kind of keep
track of people's moods
if you're trying to do that with 10 or
11 people it ends up having impos being
impossible to have one conversation
that really works for everyone if
there's real interdependence
okay so we've got two more
uh connect people and cascade excellence
and let's go through this one quickly in
the name of time uh the basic idea here
is that if you want to spread excellence
uh you can't just spread a thin coat so
just test one speech or a bit of
training
you've got to create a real deep pocket
of excellence and spread it from one to
the other
that's what happened in the hundred
thousand lives campaign once the hostel
became expert it led the others
uh to give you another quick example one
of our favorite ones
is in iraq there was a group of soldiers
who figured out
that uh when the bad guys threw an
arcade g3 cam grenade special kind of
hand grenade at a truck if it hit
something soft it wouldn't blow up
they put a trampoline on their truck and
it worked they bounced off so pretty
soon through something called the army
lessons learned
that was spread throughout the iraq
theater
another more serious one a more intense
spread of excellence that we studied at
a pharmaceutical firm called wyatt
what they would do is they do these mini
transformations and you can see
the example on the slide where they'd
really get one group really really
humming
and then somebody like fifi would then
lead the effort to spread to the next
and then the next
the next part of the plant and then you
end up with this transformation where we
see
where production almost doubles as a
result of spreading excellence from
where it is to where it isn't
but in an intense sort of way
okay now our final principle and
maybe our favorite which is that and
this is sort of a play on the great
business book i'm good to great
by jim collins it's our assertion if you
want to spread excellence it's more
important
to go from bad to great than good to
great because bad is stronger than good
there's all sorts of evidence that if
you look at an incredible list of bad
behaviors
and bad people and bad actions and bad
mood
stealing uh corruption
anything you look at that's bad that's
so much stronger than good that if you
don't get rid of it
you're going to have problems spreading
excellence in your organizations
uh just you know two quick examples it
turns out that
if you have a bad interaction with one
of your co-workers
or with um or with your boss
it packs five times the wallop on mood
and productivity is a good one
or some other research if you've got one
deadbeat or jerk in your organization
it undermines performance by 30 or 40
percent
so when we look at scaling people are
really good at they're always thinking
like
what's getting in the way so one quick
example
barry fell the guy who was a guest in
our scaling
class he took over a chain of at that
time about 180 retail stores
on the west coast or some in texas and
other parts of the western united states
and and in the process he visited almost
everyone
in part to figure out which ones to
close but also to spread the method
the message that there's certain bad
behaviors we've got to get rid of
and two things he really focused on was
do they greet me and other customers
and two are the bathrooms clean because
his theory was if you guess just get rid
of those simple bad behaviors dirty
bathrooms and not
reading that things would get better in
the chain and in fact it worked
he turned it around and it was sold to
bath and beyond recently
and another example a more simple one to
sort of get back to the sort of
cognitive overload case
our buddy chris fry when he was brought
in as head of engineering at twitter
he actually faced quite an interesting
challenge
when many of us may know who used
twitter there was a point where the fail
whale was coming up constantly and
his job was among other things to get
rid of the fail whale and he noticed in
his first meetings
that um instead of talking and people
were looking at their cell phones
his engineering team so what he does now
is he collects them
and and to give you some confirmation
that i'm not just bsing you
um a while back um one of the members of
his senior team
uh sent out a twitter and sort of put my
twitter handles work matters and put
work
matters in it and and i'll interpret it
for you chry rule
cell phones must be deposited with rj
san jose that's his
executive assistant prior to the start
of the meeting and you can see the cell
phones on the table
so the key thing about getting this bad
is stronger than good stuff it isn't
just big bad behavior
so it can be little things you got to
chip away at all the time
all right so those are the scaling
principles that we talked about there's
more in the book on scaling up
excellence
let me make let me make kind of a final
wrap-up point and tell a little story
and then we're going to hear a little
bit from ryan um
so so a kind of parting thought one of
the things
that um actually disturbs me well and
it's a thing that i probably commit
myself
and maybe have committed in this in this
uh in this little session here
is that um very often we tell stories
about organizations that change or go
through transformation including scaling
it sounds like this beautiful smooth
process where people actually know what
they're doing and
they're kind of happily moving along at
every stage
but at least if you look at some cases
of
where the app actually happens or if
you're in the middle of one yourself
there are always long stretches of
confusion there's peers where things go
wrong
it seems messed up and as the quote from
david kelly says
one of my heroes it turns out that
this is just sort of like life as usual
in organizations
and to be able to scale excellence or to
do any other sort of real organizational
change where you're doing something
different you've got to accept it in
some ways that you clean up things as
well as you can
but you're also in the middle of a
manageable mess and you've got to keep
muddling forward the best you can
even though things aren't going
particularly well at the moment
and just one little tip since i've got
another minute or two that i would
like to emphasize is a little trick that
i've seen david use and is also
supported by some awfully good social
psychology
is that one way to get people to stop
focus on
focusing on how difficult things are and
to stop being freaked out and upset
is to get them not so much to think
about now but to think about the past or
the future
so turn their attention to the time in
the past
when they faced a similarly difficult
situation
and were able to overcome it so the idea
of sort of you know
the retrospection might not even be
accurate but it helps them get through
it
or to have them focus on the future
and and to get people motivated about a
dream or vision that lies ahead so
ironically one of the great things
that leaders do to help people muddle
through the mess of scaling and other
sorts of organizational changes
is to have them switch attention away
from the never ending now the perpetual
present tense we're all trapped in to a
brighter future
in times when they got through the
problem in the past
okay so that's the end of our
official webinar and it's time to turn
it over to ryan
bob thank you so much really very much
appreciate it before we leave wanted to
make sure that you
have professor sutton's information his
blog
again this is his most recent
publication the scaling of excellence
with professor heidegger varal so
if you're interested in more we strongly
encourage you to either follow bob or
get the book
and i think our first question there is
if problems pop up when team sizes grow
beyond six
how do you create an efficient hierarchy
for a large organization what would
become
would it become a huge tree so so it is
sort of interesting because one
thing that people talk about a lot is
this notion would have organizations be
as flat as possible
and um and
so um one thing one thing that sort of
helps
to think about is is organizations and i
would sort of give you
everything from walmart to the us army
to mckenzie the um
the consulting firm that they do have
multiple layers
but the if you will the sort of finding
unit where the action
actually really happens tends to be in
four-person teams
and so so what you'll have is as flat a
hierarchy as you can possibly get
get away with but but you don't have to
have four four four four four all the
way up
you actually can um you actually can
structure an organization
in part by doing two things
that reduce the need for sort of close
supervision and therefore lots of
hierarchy
the first thing and this gets back to
the mindset stuff
so that when people are kind of all on
the same page about how we're supposed
to behave
what's sacred and what's taboo here you
actually don't need as much close
supervision you probably do need some
close supervision
you do need managers to do things like
provide some direction
to deal with the difficult team members
and to do
other sort of standard sort of things
that are always part of organizations
and the other thing that we're learning
is that the best
organizations one thing that they do to
eliminate the need for so many levels
and so much close supervision is that
when people are on similar time rhythms
uh it it and that's one of the
organizations that we
studied for the book salesforce.com was
actually chris fry
work in terms of helping to turn around
their development organization
what he did was he put all the teams and
these were small five-person engineering
teams
he put them on a rhythm where they had
daily stand-up meetings
every week they had have a prototype
every couple of weeks they have
have a demo and and then they would
exactly every four weeks they'd have to
have a demo
and then every four months they'd all
release a product together
and what happens when people are in the
same time rhythm you don't have to watch
them as closely because they sort of all
know what to do and when to hurry and
they also know
the pressures that others are under so
the collaboration and cooperation
is smooth so yes there is some tension
between the notion that smaller
teams are more effective and it might
lead to more hierarchy
but organizations do find ways around it
and in particular what the best
organizations do it
it's interesting to look at walmart
actually because walmart
is huge as an organization as it is from
the sales associate on the floor to the
ceo it's only about eight levels
so it's actually a quite bureaucratic we
all know it's like it's a very
bureaucratic
organization but it's also quite
efficient because
um they they sort of break people into
small teams in in groups
but they don't they create as little
hierarchy as possible in between
but that's a great question and there's
a constant tension
between it and one sort of final word i
would emphasize
there's a lot of rhetoric out there that
flatter
and decentralize and empowerment is
always better
and the answer in that case is to be
very careful because there's sometimes
when you do need some
more hierarchy okay another question
okay go for it well well i so i like
this
one um so
okay when do you get rid of dead beats
how do you realize their effect this is
they're affecting the team
or you should take time to try to
professionally develop them first
so my perspective i can't tell you
exactly the time when it's time to get
rid of a deadbeat and in fact in some
organizations
it might be so difficult to get rid of
them that you may not even have that
option to be perfectly honest
but if you look at research on what the
most effective
managers do uh what they tend to do is
they tend to nip
bad behavior in the bud and when they
see bad behavior
what they'll do is is they'll react to
it quickly and give people negative
feedback
a little guidance little coaching then
maybe a formal warning and if it's
possible to fire them
to fire them there's actually quite good
research that when leaders act that way
not only do they run teams that perform
more effectively
they actually are more well liked by the
people that they lead
in terms of the development stuff one
thing that's actually sort of
interesting
that i always think is an important
footnote is to go to the google play
book
and one thing google which is they're
incredibly evidence-based one thing
they've figured out
is sometimes when you have actually a
poorly performing
employee or manager that sometimes
because of regression to the mean and
other forces that if they just take the
person and put them in a different team
they sometimes improve dramatically
about 25 or 30 percent of the time
because sometimes they're just something
about the context that doesn't fit their
skills and personalities
so i really like that idea in terms of
nipping the bad behavior in the
bud rather than really working on
changing the person's
style and personality and fitting better
in the team uh maybe the first order of
business is let's
put them somewhere else if you can do it
and see if they if they can thrive in
that situation
um so we have time for one more question
i think we've got if you can answer it
quickly we have time for one more
okay um could you comment on the role of
error and driving
insights and innovation um it's
absolutely i don't like the word error
the reason i don't like the word air i
would prefer the word failure mistake
things that don't work out
there's absolutely no way to do anything
new
without making without doing things that
don't turn out well
and and my friend diego rodriguez who's
actually he's he's also
um in our in our course on leading
innovation he's a great saying which is
uh
which is failure sucks but instructs and
in the best
teams and organizations that are doing
innovative work they fail constantly but
the main difference i would make is the
ones that are
led well they make mistakes and learn
from them and therefore make different
mistakes
and the ones that are bad it's like a
kabuki dance they make the same mistake
over and over again so to me that's the
diagnostic difference
and i wish i had more time for your
comments and for your questions and i
love
this long beautiful list but it's 10
o'clock and we must end on time so i
think i've got to turn it over to
somebody else to wrap it up
with that i want to again thank
professor sutton for his time and and
insights
i know that i'm challenged to go back
and try to do things differently
uh and we'll see how effective i am at
this time then i'd like to say thank you
for joining us
thank you
you